J'étais celui qui roulait
professionnellement, j'étais celui qui suivait
les traces de notre père dans mon rêve de courir
le passé de mon petit frère Rice et pose des méchants poussiéreux
de l'année pendant une journée record à temps plein
moi un autre mort ses
tasses de carburant étonne toujours les gens
c'est toujours la course qui arrête une nation
d'ailleurs tout le monde de la course des
chevaux une créature d'habitude
toute déviation des chevaux qui suit aura
un impact significatif vous êtes celui qui
peut tirer le meilleur parti de mon cheval
des
chevaux fantastiques imparables mais le droit  Jackie
peut être un casse-tête pourrait les gagner et
venez voir ce que vous avez s'il vous plaît pas
encore vous êtes mort Jason une fois qu'il peut être
votre tour quel diamant jetez-le simplement
Je sais que vous vous en sortirez
c'est dans votre sang être parfois  un
champion ne consiste pas à gagner,
il s'agit de le couper si M n'est pas
maudit
ce n'est pas le même homme qui a gagné en juillet
je crois que c'est le seul homme à écrire que la
dernière coupe ce sera juste dans ce nom le
mien est une internatio  public final d'
environ 700 millions lorsque vous courez pour le
flic, je ne crois pas que vous serez en ce moment
longtemps
nous avons quelque chose de très spécial Damian
mais votre cœur doit y être vous
savez Bhushan
ces braconniers
c'est déjà ça  tout peut arriver
c'est le plafond du réseau